[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
روسيا تتعاهد بتطويرت رسالتها النوويه
والنيتو يوقع اتفاقيه لتوسيع التعاون مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي
ولي العهد السعودي يواجه بدراسه زياده
الاستثمارات والوديعه في باكستان الى اكثر
من 15 مليار دولار
ملامح حجي هذا العام تتضح لا قيود ولا
شروط والعوده الى الاعداد الطبيعيه لما
قبلنا
في الرابعه ايضا
بعد موجه امطار تاريخيه الرابع الرابعه
تتجول في وادي فاطمه احد اشهر الاوديه في
مكه المكرمه
لا يتوقف حيث وقع خلف الناتو والاتحاد
الاوروبي اعلان للتعاون والتنسيق يتضمن
بدعم اوكرانيا في مواجهه روسيا الامين
العام لخلف شمال الاطلسي ستورمبرج قال ان
الخلفه والكتله الاوروبيه يجب ان يستمر في
تقويه شركتهما لمواجهه نظام بوتن كما اضاف
بانه يجب زياده الدعم المقدم لاوكرانيا
لحلف الناتو والاتحاد الاوروبي لتطوير
الشراكه بيننا منذ قرابه العام وساعات بعد
اجتياح روسيه لاوكرانيا في الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير التقينا هنا في مقر
الناتو الرئيس بوتل اراد ان يسيطر على
اوكرانيا في ايام قليله واراد ان يقسمنا
ولا قد فشل في الامرين معا وبشكل واضح
القوه الروسيه تم دحرها من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه الباسله والنيت والاتحاد
الاوروبي
اوكرانيا النظام في موسكو يريد اوروبا
مختلفه يريد السيطره على جيرانه وهو يرى
الحريه والديمقراطيه كتهديد الله وسيكون
لهذا اثر
البعيد ولهذا يجب ان يستمر في تقويه
الروابط بين اعضاء ويجب ان يستمر في تقويه
الشراكه بين النيته والاتحاد الاوروبي
نزيد دعمنا لاوكرانيا
ونبقى في تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث شدد
وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجيو شوريغو بان
بلاده ستواصل العمل على تطوير الثالوث
النووي والحفاظ على جاهزيه القتاليه واشار
خلال اجتماع الموسع مع قاده الجيش الروسي
الى ان الدرع النوويه كان ولا يزال الضامن
الرئيسيه لسياده روسيا والسلامه
واجهزه الدفاع الجوي الحديثه ولفت الى ان
الخطط الفوريه
الحديثه وتطوير المعدات والتجهيزات
العسكريه الى اعلى مستوى في عام 2000 و
يعجبنا قاعده
النووي والحفاظ على استعداده القتالي لان
الدرع النووي كان ولا يزال ضامنا الرئيسي
لسياده البلاد وسلامه اراضيها سنعمل ايضا
على زياده القدرات القتاليه للقوات الجويه
ومن بينها عمل المقاتلات والقاذفات في
المناطق التي تعمل فيها انظمه الدفاع
الجوي الحديثه وكذلك تحسين الطائرات بدون
طيار
صوتك
اول مناورات عسكريه بعد دخولها الخدمه في
بحر النرويج وقالت الدفاع الروسيه ان
المناورات تركزت على مواجهه اهداف جويه
باسلحه الناريه مضاد للطائرات وتدميرها
وكان رئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوت نكد خلال
اطلاق الفرقاطه المسلحه للصواريخ سيركون
ان بلاده ستواصل تطوير القدرات القتاليه
بالقوات المسلحه وانتاج اسلحه متطوره
قال سكرتير مجلس الامن الروسي نيكولاس
باتشيب ان صراع في اوكرانيا تحول الى صراع
بين روسيا والنيتو واضاف في تصريحات
اوردتها وكاله النفوستي ان الولايات
المتحده والغرب اعدت السلطات في اوكرانيا
لشني هجمات ضد روسيا وتقطيع اوصالها
واشاره ايضا الان الانسحاب المفاجئه
للولايات المتحده من افغانستان كان غرضه
التركيز على اوكرانيا
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
بدراسه زياده الاستثمارات السعوديه في
باكستان المعلنه في الخامس والعشرين من
اغسطس الماضي لتصل الى 10 مليارات دولار
وفقا لوكاله الانباء السعوديه كما يدرس
الصندوق السعودي الى التنميه زياده مبلغ
الوديعه المقدمه لصالح البنك المركزي
الباكستانيه المعلني عنها في الثاني من
ديسمبر الماضي
من اسلام اباد الصحفي احمد قريشي سيد احمد
اهلا وسهلا بك معي
اسلام ابادي الى هذا الموقف الان من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بالتفكير في
زياده استثماراتها في اسلام ابابا
خطوه استراتيجيه مهمه جدا يا اخوي خالد من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه حقيقه دارسين
العلاقه الباكستانيه السعوديه
في المملكه دعم الباكستان واكثر من سبعه
عقود يعني
دائما
وسياسيا لحركه الاستقلال الباكستانيه في
الاربعينيات من القرن الماضي ومرورا
بالعقود السبعه الماضيه علاقه استراتيجيه
سياسيه ثقافيه امنيه عسكريه متدره فالموقف
همم السعوديه وموقف سمو العهد لم يكن
مفاجاه ان همم بالنسبه لباكستان لكنه مهم
وهمم جدا نظرا للظرف المناخي والكارثه
والاسماء التي تمر بها باكستان والحصان
الدعم الدولي في قيمه المواقف طبعا لانه
هناك
ازمات كثيره
وبدء ان يدعم باكستان وراينا نموذج لذلك
الدعم في مؤتمر جنين اليوم
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي بزياده
الاستثمار وبالتالي يعني ما هي اهم
المزايا والمقومات التنافسيه التي تمتلك
باكستان اليوم والتي تجعل السعوديه تتجه
الى زياده الاستثمار اليها فيها ب 10
مليار
هناك امور كثيره يعني
واحده من الاقتصاد جاد التي تنمو بشكل
سريع في اسيا
ويجد ان هناك
شهيه كبيره
للاستثمارات في مجالات الطاقه في مجالات
استهلاكيه في مجالات التكنولوجيا حوالي
230 نسمه عدد سكان باكستان نصفهم همم
يستخدمون مثلا الانترنت ادوات التكنولوجيا
الحديثه هناك اهتمام كبير يعني
همم من طرف الصين همم الشركات الامريكيه
الكبرى وايضا
ارامكو السعوديه همم
والحكومه السعوديه طبعا فهناك ميزات كثيره
يعني همم لكن الاهميه اهمها همم
الجانب الاستراتيجي خالد
الباكستان والسعوديه عندما عملها معا
وتعاونها همم بلدان قام بتغيير يعني همم
مجرى الاحداث السياسيه في هذه المنطقه بدا
من الحرب البارده حرب افغانستان همم
شيوعيه واا الحروب الاخيره التي رايناها
في افغانستان والان مثلا على سبيل المثال
نجد ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وباكستاني يتعاونان وربما هم بالبلدان
الذين يمكنهما ان يؤثران على حكومه حركه
طالبان في افغانستان فيما يتعلق واخرى
فالدور والتعاون السعودي الباكس يعني مهم
ليس فقط اقتصاديا وانما ايضا استراتيجيا
وعسكريا وامنيا هذه الابعاد الاستراتيجيه
الى اي مدى يمكن ان تنعكس على الملفات في
في المنطقه تحدثت عن موضوع افغانستان لكن
في في المنطقه ايران على سبيل المثال همم
كذلك تداعيات الحرب الروسيه لك الاوكرانيه
كيف يمكن النظر الى هذا يعني
تشارك ربما الاستراتيجي بين بين اسلام بدر
الرياض
سؤال مهم جدا يا اخوي خالد طبعا باكستان
في موقف صعب ازاء ايران لان يبدو ان
الباكستانيين لا يريدون ان يجذبوا انتباه
الحرس الثوري الايراني والمليشيات
الايرانيه نحوهم كانوا يودون لو ان تبقى
هذه الميليشيات وهذا التاثير الايراني
بعيده عن باكستان لكن باكستان متضرره من
من هذه الامور ايضا فنجد الان على سبيل
المثال باكستاني جزء من التعاون الاقليمي
العسكري
في خليج عدن في البحر الاحمر وفي خليج
عمان وبحر العرب مع همم
البحريه السعوديه والبحريه الامريكيه همم
لوقف انجازات الاسلحه همم غير قانونيه الى
دخولها الى اليمن على سبيل المثال من ضمن
همم مظله الاسطول الخامس البحريه الامريكي
الناشط في هذه البطاقه وهناك امور كثيره
هناك تعاون عسكري طبعا هما هناك امور
تعاون العسكري اكبر من مجرد هذا المثال
همم اكبر بكثير همم ربما
المسؤولين الباكستانيين لا يحبون
علنا عن هذا التعاون ربما همم لانهم
يريدون اهتمام او لا يريدون اثاره انتباه
الحرس الثوري الايراني
التي تضررت باكستان ايضا منها همم خصوصا
فيما يتعلق
بمليشيا الزين التي قامت باستقطاب عدد من
الشبان الباكستانيين اللي همم
الحرب في في سوريا وايضا دور الايراني
ايضا في داخل افغانستان فهناك ملف امني
استراتيجي مهم جدا يجمع ما بين باكستان
ومن المملكه العربيه السعوديه يشمل
الافغانستان يشمل ايران يشمل اليمن يشمل
الوضع الاقليمي عموما في هذه المنطقه وهذا
التعاون الاستراتيجي واستمر شكرا جزيلا لك
من اسلام اباد الصحفي احمد قريش
ونذهب الى بروكسل الان التي تشهد انعقاد
مؤتمرات الثوره الديمقراطيه الايرانيه
والذي تشارك فيه شخصيات دوليه وازنه دعت
اليه منظمه مجاهد خلق ومنظمه اللجنه
الدوليه للبحث في العهد من مقر المؤتمر في
بروكسل ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه نور
الدين الفريق نور مرحبا بك نور ما الذي
يحمله هذا الموسم
يعني في غزون للمداخلات السابقه حتى
اللحظه والمؤتمر المتوسط هناك اسئله مهمه
طرحت واسئله عمليه طرحت على في المؤتمر من
بينها هل
يمكن للاتحاد الاوروبي او لم يحن الوقت
للاتحاد الاوروبي كي يصنف جهاز الحرس
الثوري بكامله ضمن المنظمات الارهابيه الم
يحن الوقت بالنسبه للدول الاوروبيه كانت
تتخذ اجراءات الدبلوماسيه حاسمه بالنسبه
للوجود الايراني في همم في اوروبا او
الوجود الاوروبي في في طهران تحدثت
وهي همم مواطنه فرنسيه كولومبيا همم عرفت
بانها كانت مرشحه ولكن بالاساس كانت سنوات
وهي رهينه لدى ال- بعد المجموعات المسلحه
فيه كلهم الانبياء تحدث عن ورده او حاولت
الرد عند التساؤل عن همم هناك بديل للنظام
الايراني
المجلس الوطني للمقاومه الايرانيات يمثل
البديل ذي المصداقيه تحدثت عن هذه الثوره
غير المسبوقه والتي تقودها المراه
والرجل قد التحق بها ولكن قالت ايضا انه
حان الوقت بالنسبه للاتحاد الاوروبي ان
يقف الى جانب مريم رجوي مثلما وقفت الدول
الغربيه قبل نحو 40 عاما عندما نفضت يديها
او ايديها من نظام الشاه ودعمت همم خميني
انا ذاك بقوه وترى انجري بيكون بان حان
الوقت لان يعيد الغرب مره اخرى هذا الدعم
الكلي ولكن للسيد مريم رجوي زعيم
مجلس المقاومه الايرانيه همم ايضا همم
حاول ويتحدث المؤتمر عن عن هذا البديل
ويرون من ان البديل يتوفر في نظرهم في
المجلس الوطني للمقاومه في المجاهدين خلق
ولكن يقولون من انها هذا التنظيم يجب ان
يكون الديمقراطيا متعد يقبل به تمثيل همم
الاقليات القوميه ولكن المعروف ان خارج
هذا المؤتمر ان مجموعات عده من الشعوب في
ايران لا تجدوا لها تمثيلا او هي ليست
ربما في قطيعه او لا تتحدث همم لا نراها
في تحالف مع مجاهدي خلق مثلا تلاقي
البالوش او همم الحوازيين الازهريين هناك
حركات عده لا تزال 9 حضرنا كلمه اخيره في
محاوله بزلها ان هو ابن اوروبيون في مكان
اخر في البرلمان الاوروبي يدعو فيها
المعارضه الايرانيه وخاصه الى القوميه الى
تشكيله
هذا التحالف يكونوا بديلا او يكون حاضرا
في الوقت المناسب يعني هذه نقاشات خارج
الاتحاد همم رئيس المفوضيه قالت اليوم ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي سيواصل الضغط على ايران
واتخاذ عقوبات ضد ايران وكذلك ضد روسيا
على خلفيه تدعمه همم همم كلت الدولتين ل
همم الحمله العسكريه الروسيه على اوكرانيا
خالد اشكرك شكرا جزيلا من بروكسل من مقر
المؤتمر مراسل العربي نور الدين فرضيه
في الرابعه بعد قليل
خلال شهرين فقط اصدار اكثر من 750 الف
تاشيره عمره للمعتمرين الافراد من خارج
السعوديه
اهلا بكم من جديد فهذا ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز بلقب
القائد العربي الاكثر تاثيرا عام 2022
للعام الثاني على التوالي وفق استطلاع
للراي اجرته قناه روسيا اليوم الناطقه
بالعربيه حصل ولي العهد السعودي على نحو
سبعه ملايين400 الف صوت من اجمالي 12
مليون صوت شاركوا في الاستفتاء ما يشكله
ثلاثه من العشره في المئه من الاصوات وهو
رقم قياسي في تاريخ استطلاعات الرايه التي
تجريها روسيا اليوم نهايه كل عام
يوصلوا معرض اكسبو الحلقه
اليوم الثاني وسط حضور عدد من المسؤولين
والوفود من عده دول حول العالم واكد عدد
من المختصين في منظومه الحج والعمره خلال
مشاركتهم في المعرض على دور المنصات
الرقميه في تقليل الوقت المستغرق لانهاء
اجراءات القدوم خلال اقل من ثلاث دقائق
وذلك ضمن مبادره طريق مكه احدى مبادره
برنامج او برامج رؤيه المملكه 2030
جميله العنود العبدلي تعطينا شيئا من
ملامح موسمي حج هذا العمل 2023
الى وضع الطبيعي دون قيود او شروط بنفس
الاعداد لمواسم ما قبل الجائحه وفقا لاخر
احصائيات الرسميه لجائحه كورونا فقد وصل
عدد الحجاج لعام 2019 الى نحو اثنين ونصف
مليون حاجه لكن مشاهدينا ماذا عن
الاشتراطات المرتبطه بالتحصيل الحجاج
القادمين من خارج السعوديه وزاره الحج
والعمره بينت العربيه انه يشتر التلقي
الحاج ثلاثه تحصينات ضد كورونا ضد الحمى
الشوكيه اضافه الى لقاح الانف وانزا
الموسميه وهو ينطبق على حجاج الداخل كما
اعلن سابقا وتشهد مدينه جده مشاهدينا
استمرار اعمال اليوم الثاني من معرض
ومؤتمر اكسبو الحاج وذلك بمشاركه واحد و80
متحدثا من القطاعين العام والخاص ووفود من
سبعه او سبعه وخمسين دوله حول العالم
العمليه لتحسين تجربه الحجاج
نعود لنذكر بما اكده وزير الحج والعمره
الدكتور توفيق الربيع انه حج هذا العام لن
يشترط فيه حد اعلى لاعمار الحجاج والذي
كان مقررا في العام الماضي عند 65 عاما
كما كشفت او كما كشف الربيع خلال كلمته في
معرض اكسبو الحاج عن تخفيض تكلفه التامين
على حجاج هذا العام بنسبه ثلاثه وسبعين
بالمئه لتصبح عند 87 ريال فقط
بشارتين
في هذا اللقاء
البشره الاولى
عوده اعداد الحجاج الى ما كانت عليه قبل
الجائحه وبدون اي قيود على العمر
بعثه من اي دوله في العالم عاده ترتبط
بمؤسسه خدمات واحده
في خدمات الحج
ولتعزيز التنافسيه
وتطوير الخدمات وتعزيز الان وابتداء من
هذا العام اي بعثه الحج اي مكتب حج من اي
مكان في العالم يستطيع التعاقد مع اي شركه
مرخصه تحقق المتطلبات اللي يحتاجها حجاج
هذه الدوله
في معرضي ومؤتمر اكسبو الخجل 2023 حيث كشف
محافظ هيئه الحكومه الرقميه احمد الصويان
انه جرى اصداره اكثر من 750 الف تاشيره
عمره لمعتمرين افراد خلال اقل من شهرين
منذ بدء موسم العمره الحالي مضيفا بان من
اولويات هيئه الحكومه رقميه دمج من الصوت
والتحول من 36 من الصافي قطاع الحج الى
منصه نسك مشيرا الى ان منصه نوسه تقدم 100
واحد وعشرين خدمه تتنوعه بين قطاع الاعمال
والافراد لخدمه 30 مليون شخص
من جده من مقر المعرض والمؤتمر ينضم الينا
المهندس محمد ابو الخير اسماعيل رئيس
تنفيذي لبرنامج ضيوف الرحمن مهندس محمد
حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه
من المعرض يعني المعرض 2023
لماذا هو مهم لخدمه ضيوف الرحمه
حياكم الله استاذ خالد
الحجاج الى الاعداد الطبيعيه
لجميع المسلمين
جميعا
همم الحج والعمره عوده الله يسلمكم الى
سؤالكم بخصوص اكس اكس
منصه او خليني اقول القبه التي يجتمع
تحتها صانع القرار
خدمات الحج والعمره يجتمع تحتها كذلك
ممثلي المستفيدين من شتى انحاء العالم
لمناقشه كافه الخدمات وكافه الترتيبات
التي تتعلق بالحج ااا وخدماته نسعى من
خلال اكس والحج بالشراكه مع كافه الجهات
التي تعمل فيه الى الفروج بافضل طريقه يتم
خدمه ضيوف الرحمن فيه بشكل ابتكاري وتقني
ونتحاول ان نقدم افضل الخامات لهم من خلال
من خلال مقدمي سلسله من مقدمه خدمات
والشركاته
اهم التغيرات التي احدثتها مع الشركاء
والى اي مدى يمكن ان تنعكس على رحله الحاج
هذا العام خاصه مع عوده الارقام الى ما
قبل الجائع
لعلي ابني في هذه النقطه استاذ خالد
علامات تفضل بذكر سابق وبعد تفضل في ميعاد
الشويان الا وهو منصف نفسك وهي تحد احد
مبادرات برنامج خدمه الضيوف الرحمن والتي
نسعى من خلالها الى تقديم تجربه رقميه
مميزه جدا للحجاج والمعتمرين كذلك همم
التنوين على واحده من اكثر المبادرات
الناجحه الخاصه بقياده وزاره الداخليه
مكه والتي ااهل اجراءات قدوم الخاصه
بالحجاج همم الجهود بفضل الله تعالى كبيرا
يتشارك معنا فيها القطاع الحكومي بشكل
جلالات المدنيه والعسكريه وكذلك القطاع
الخاص همم الثالث من ضمن الاشياء كذلك
التي نسعى الى تقديمها بشكل متميز هو
تاهيل العاملين في قطاع الحج والعمره
ااا بما يجعلهم يقدمون الخدمه ويتعاملون
بعد الحجاج المعتمرين بشكل راقي يتواكب مع
جهود المملكه العربيه السعوديه وما تبذلوا
في خدمه الدجاجه
الكافات الخدمه التي تحدثت عنها ومساله
ايضا اثراء التجربه ضمن برنامج خدمه ضيوف
الرحمن وضمن التوجه ايضا في في رؤيه
المملكه 2030 مثل هذا التجمع اليوم كيف
يمكن ان يسهم في تحقيقه تحقيق هذين
الهدفين او اهداف بشكل
شهرين قرابه الشهرين تم اطلاق ثمانيه
مواقع تاريخيه تم تاهيلها وتجديدها
للزوار
من خلال هذا المؤتمر عملنا على وجود همم
جناح متكامل يشرح هذه التجربه عن طريقه
السينما الاندوماسيه حيث يستطيع ممثلي
الحجاج وكل من يزور هذا المعرض من استشعار
هذه التجربه ان يعيش وهذه التجربه وكانهم
داخل هذه المواقع همم التاريخيه همم اعطاء
هذا البعد الذي يتعلق وتوضيح هذا البعد
التي يتعلق باثراء التجربه انه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
وانما تمتد كذلك الى ان يعيش وتجربه
ثقافيه ترسخ في اذهانهم همم ويعود بها
بافضل الذكريات الان في المعرض مثلا هذه
الموجود كيف ممكن تقدم الخدمه او تجذب
ربما شركات المهتمه خارج المملكه في
تعاقدات معها في مساله كذلك انه تكون رحله
همم تؤدي الغرض همم يعني دينيا وكمان تثري
تجربه هذا الشخص الذي يصل الى المملكه من
عند الجوانب ومجالات
المشاركين في هذا
[موسيقى]
الاكس بوكس من صحه تعبير يزيد عمي 200
خدمه
استاذ خالد لا تشتمل فقط على الجانبيه
ولكن كذلك جانب الخدمات المصاحب لاحجاج
والمعتبرين
في البرنامج درسنا ما يزيد عن 100 و90
نقطه اتصال للحجاج والمعتمرين نسعى من
خلال هذه الشركات ومن خلال كذلك القطاع
الحكوميه ان نوفر سلسله كامله
التي تتبعها المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
تقديم الخدمات احنا نتكلم
عن خدمات الاستقبال والتوديع نتكلم عنه
عندما
السكن العاشر
والمعتمر رحله متناغمه ومتكامله همم ان
تكون بجانب الامن والطمانين والصحه في
المقام الاول وكذلك يخدم فيها الحاج على
مدار الساعه احدث همم
ال- الاشترافات وافضل همم المعاجم شكرا
جزيلا لك المهندس محمد ابو الخير اسماعيل
الرئيس تنفيذي لبرنامج ضيوف الرحمن من مقر
اكسبو الحاج 20 همم 23 من جده شكرا لكم
رابع ايضا مستمره فيها بعد قليل بعد موجه
امطار تاريخيه الرابعه تتجول في وادي
فاطمه احد اشهر الاوديه في مكه المكرمه
روسيا تتعهد بتطوير ترسانتها النوويه
والنيتو يوقع اتفاقيه لتوسيع التعاون مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي
ولي العهد السعودي يواجهوا بالدراسه زياده
الاستثمارات والوديعه في باكستاني اكثر من
15 مليار دولار
ملامح حج هذا العام تتضح لا قيود ولا شروط
والعوده الى الاعداء الطبيعيه لما قبلنا
وبعد موجه امطار تاريخيه الرابعه تتجول في
وادي فاطمه احد اشهر الاوديه في مكه
المكرمه
اهلا بكم بعد اعلان ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان عن ضمه مشروع
الدرعيه ليصبح خامس خامسه مشاريع صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه الكبرى زميل عبد
المحسن الحربي وثق واقع المشروع حاليا في
جوله ليليه
بعد ان اصبح مشروع الدرعيه واجزاء منه
التي افتتحت اولى المشاريع التي يشاهدها
المواطن
والمقيم وكذلك السائح المرتبطه بشكل كامل
برؤيه 20 30 بعد ان تم افتتاح هذا الموقع
قبل اسابيع قليله حيث في التاريخ
ومطل البجيري اليوم على صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه عن ضم مشاريع الدرعيه بشكل عام
لكافه مشاريع صندوق الاستثمارات العامه
التي يعمل عليها وهي خمسه مشاريع كبرى يتم
العمل عليها من قبل صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه هي نيوم والبحر الاحمر وكذلك همم
الجديه ومشروع همم روشن وكذلك مشروع همم
الدرعيه اخيرا حيث همم متوقع ان يتم
الاعلان عن عدد من الفرص من قبل صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه في هذا المشروع في همم
مراحل تطويره اللاحقه حيث واا ستتخصص في
عدد من القطاعات منها البناء والترشيد
والاسكان والترفيه وقطاع الضيافه كل هذه
القطاعات يتم استهدافها من قبل صندوق
السترات العامه بعد ضم همم مشروع الدرعيه
وهو مشروع ضخم على مساحه 13 كلم مربع يضم
عديد من المتاحف والمواقع التاريخيه حيث
حي طريف التاريخي وعدد من الاماكن الاخرى
التي يتم العمل عليها لاستقطاب عدد كبير
من السياح بقيمه تتجاوز 75 مليار ريال
سعودي يتم العمل على هذا المشروع وتشيده
ومتوقع ان يفتتح خلال همم اجزائه
المتكامله خلال 20 30 عبد المحسن الحربي
اهل العربيه الرياض
اشهد اسد وادي فاطمه في منطقه مكه المكرمه
غربيه السعوديه هذه الايام توافق اعداد
كبيره من الزوار الباحثين عن الطبيعه
وجمالها فضل الاستمرار الحاله المطريه
التي تشهدها المنطقه
باللون الاخضر
من اشهر السدود السعوديه عام
1985 لتغريه المصادر الجوفيه لمياه الابار
وتامين مياه الشرب في مدينتي مكه وجده
من وادي فاطمه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
سلطان السلامي سلطان مرحبا بك
المنظر ولا اروع يا سلطان بس خلينا ناخذ
معكم جوله نشوف فيها يعني هذا المنطقه
وادي فاطمه من اكثر من زاويه
مشاهدي قناه العربيه بالفعل الجو جو مكشات
وطبخ واستئناف يعني خلال الفتره الماضيه
اليومين والسميع الماضيه شهدت وادي فاطمه
وتحديدا سد وادي فاطمه الكثير المتنزهين
من اهالي منطقه مكه المكرمه وحتى الزوار
القادمين من خارج منطقه مكه المكرمه هذه
المنطقه يعني طبعا جريان للمياه والامطار
بشكل كبير جدا مما جعلها يعني بساط اخطر
اللون مع شريان للمياه في كثير من الاوديه
والمناطق المجاوره لهذا السد الذي يغذي
العديد من المزارع ولا اوديه والمناطق
الزراعيه هنا في منطقه الجنوب التي تشتهر
بكثره المزارع والاوتريه وبزاعه التمور
والليمون وغيرها من الورقيات في هذه
المنطقه يعني خلال اسابيع الماضيه كان
ممتلئ هذا الوادي بشكل كبير جدا بالزواره
متنزه له لازال ويتواجدون وتوافيدون بشكل
يومي وبشكل الاستمتاع بالاجواء الساحره
ولا صوت يعلو على صوت ربيع كما تشاهد
الجبال والاوديه مكتسبه بالخضار الكامل
رغما الامطار يعني انتهت خلال الثلاث
اربعه ايام الماضي لكن لا يزال اللون
الاخضر يطغى على هذه المناطق ربيعيه جميله
مناسبه للاستمتاع وزيارتها وقضاء الاوقات
السعيد هنا طبعا نتحدث على مناطق اخرى
كبيره جدا استفاده من هذا السد الذي
يستطيع احتواء 20 مليون متر مكعب من
المياه من ما جاء على هذه المنطقه خضراء
وتجري فيها المياه واستردت الكثير من
المناطق الزراعيه
والحيويه هنا من اهالي المنطقه الاثريه من
هذا الوادي وادي فاطمه تحدث انه ياتي من
همم قمم من جبال الطائف فصول الى محافظه
جده ويصب مياه هذا الوادي في البحر الاحمر
وادي كبير يبلغ طول القرابه 210 كيلو متر
ولدي نستضيف معي الاستاذ عبد الهادي
العتيبي وهو احد اهالي هذه المنطقه للحديث
عن كيف كانت هذه الاجواء وهذه المنطقه
خلال ايام الماضيه وشهاده اهلا وسهلا بك
على شاشه العربيه اجواء جميله خضره نشاهد
جريان المياه قرب السد كيف كانت هذه
المنطقه خلال الايام الماضيه السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته المنطقه هذه كانت قبل
السد شبه قاحله يعني سبحان الله فاراد
الله صارت بالجمال هذا الخبر الطبيعي
والجمال الطبيعي هذا طيب انا بسالك ابو
عبد الهادي ابو مجاهد عن المنطقه ايش
المياه اللي تغديها المزارع او المزارع
اتغديها مياه سد وادي فاطمه
بصفه عامه للجمهور جميله جدا وتغذي الريان
والطرفان والمناطق اللي مرتفعه فوق السد
وهذه المنطقه كلها سبحان الله
السد بهذا الشكل واللون الاخضر الذي يكتسي
الارض بشكل كامل وادي فاطمه كثير من
الاوديه والمناطق في العاصمه المقدسه كيف
شفت المنظر ده بعد انقطاع سنوات
هذه يمكن اكثر من 10 سنوات بس انا هذه
سبحان الله ما قدر الله وراءك لكن الواجب
عامه جميل يعني
وشفتوا زوار من خارج المنطقه موجودين هنا
من جميع انحاء المنطقه الغربيه من جده من
مكه من ضواحي الجموم والوادي هذا كله كل
يوم في زياده زوار
جيران المياه في سد وادي فاطمه
لكن الامور كلها سهله كلها يعني
خالد انا اعطيك يعني دعوه رسميه من قبل
ومن قبل اهالي منطقه وادي فاطمه بزياره
هذه المنطقه
والاستمتاع بشكل كبير جدا بالمناظر
الطبيعيه على هذا الجبل الذي امامنا يعني
نساء كامل بالاخضر كان انا في احد المناطق
الاوروبيه بدون مبالغه يا خالد
يعطيك صوره لهذا الجبل المكتسب باللون
الاخضر بشكل كبير يعني سنوات طويله لم
نشاهد هذه المناظر في منطقه مكه المكرمه
تحديدا ولكن مع كثره هطول الامطار خلال
الفتره الماضيه مما جاء على الاوديه
والمراكز والمحافظات التابعه لمنطقه مكه
المكرمه مكتسبه بالخضار وجيران وجيران
المياه في العديد من الاوديه من مجال
الاستفاده كبيره للمزارع والاهالي وكذلك
حتى السكان متنزهين لقيوا فرصه كبيره
للاستمتاع بهذه الاجواء وهذه كذلك تتكلم
عن درجه الحراره اليوم هي لا تتجاوز ال 25
درجه مئويه وهي درجه مناسبه لاستمتاع
نتواجد حاليا في احد المناطق فقط لكن
بالقرب مني هنالك مناطق كبيره جدا وعديده
ومختلفه المواقع قرابه جده وقرابه مكه
والطائف هي مليئه بالخضار والاجواء
الطبيعيه نعم خليك تستمتها
ايضا نسوي شكرا جزيلا لك فاطمه مراسل
العربيه سلطان السلامي
المستجدات قطع السفر في السعوديه قال نائب
الرئيس التنفيذي للقطاع التجاري في مطارات
الرياض عبد العزيز العساكر انه بحلول
نهايه العام الحديث يكونوا الطيران اذا
تلقى عشره وجهات الاوروبيه جديده مؤكدا
بان مطارات الرياض تعمل على زياده استخدام
التقنيات الذاتيه لتسهيل الوصول الى خدمه
مئه مليون مسافر بحلول عام 2030
احنا نستهدف مع شركه
اننا نخليهم يطلقون تقريبا عشر وجهات
السنه هذه باذن الله وهذه كانت في البدايه
بدايه اطلاقنا اربع وان شاء الله راح
تستمري تكون 10 بحيث انها تغطي عشر وجهات
اوروبيه جديده احنا ان شاء الله نستهدف
100 مليون مسافر بحلول العام 20 30 طبعا
وخدمه المئه مليون مسافر هذه بالطريقه
التقليديه غير ما راح تكون بشكل سهل لكن
ذلك لازم يكون في استثمار في التقنيات
الان طبقنا اكثر تقنيات مثل التقنيات
التعرف على الوجه مثل التقنيه الزملاءنا
في همم في الجوازات اللي يستخدمونها
الاجراءات صارت كلها مبسطه بحكم باستخدام
التقنيه
هذا هو كشف رئيس مجموعه وزير روبرت كاري
بان قطاع الطيران في السعوديه ينمو بشكل
ملحوظ مؤكدا بان هذا النمو يتناسب مع
الاهداف التي يسعى الى تحقيقها طيران ويز
و
رائعه
173 طائره وسنصل الى 150 طائره بحلول
الصيف المقبل وهذا النمو يتلائم مع النمو
الذي تطلع لتحقيقه السعوديه تحديدا في ظل
رؤيه 20 30 حيث نشاهد ان قطاع الطيران في
السعوديه يواصل النمو بشكل ملحوظ وهو ما
يتناسب بشكل كبير مع ما نريد تحقيقه في
طيران نويز
الاخبار الرياضيه الان مع زياد عبيدات
[موسيقى]
شكرا يا خالد واهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
اعرب العديد من اعضاء اللجنه التنفيذيه
للاتحاد الفرنسي لكره القدم مع الرغبتهم
برحيل الرئيس من منصبه بحسب راديو مونت
كارلو فان اعضاء اللجنه التنفيذيه سيعقدون
اجتماعا عن طارئا للاتحاد الفرنسي من اجل
اقناع والاستقاله وكان رئيس الاتحاد
الفرنسي قد اعتذر يوم امس عن تصريحات
سابقه انتقد فيها اللاعب السابق زين الدين
زيدان
كما وجهت وكيل الاعمال السوني السويدي
اتهامات مباشره لرئيس الاتحاد الفرنسي
لكره القدم لوغريت بالقيامي بسلوك جنسيه
غير لائق وجاءت اتهامات وكيله الاعمال في
حديث لها مع صحيفه لكيب من جانبها هنات
وزيره الرياضه الفرنسيه ايميلي اوديا عبر
حسابها في تويتر وكيله الاعمال على
شجاعتها وانها ستواصل العمل على رحيل رئيس
الاتحاد الفرنسي عن منصبه والذي يشغله منذ
العام 2000 هو 2011
توجد متسابقه الفرنسي سبسيان لوب بلقب
المرحله التاسعه من لذكار المقام حاليا في
السعوديه وبدات المرحله من العاصمه
الرياضي الى منطقه حارض بمسافه وصلت الى
686 كم في وصلت مسافه المرحله الخاصه الى
358 كيلو مترا ويتصدر المتسابق القطري
ناصر العطيه الترتيب العام للرالي بفارق
مريحا اقرب ملاحقيه في اطار سعيه
للاحتفاضه
[موسيقى]
هي حلوه الهلال الليله ضيفا على الرائد في
مباراه المقدمه من الجوله الخامسه عشر من
الدوري السعودي لكره القدم وتم تقديم هذه
المباراه نظرا لارتباط الهلال بالمشاركه
في بطوله كاس العالم للانديه المقبله
وسيدخل الهلال المباراه بمعنويات عاليه
خاصه بعد فوزها على الاتحاد في الجوله
الماضيه من المسابقه ويملك الهلال 25 نقطه
مقابل 15 نقطه لفريق الرائد
وفي مباراه المؤجله من الدوري السعودي
لكره القدم تعادل الشباب مع الاتحاد بهدف
لكل منهما تفاصيل هذه المباراه في التقرير
التاليه
[موسيقى]
فيصل بن فهد في الرياض
حوض ضيافه يفتتحون فرص اللقاء بهبري يرسل
كره بعيده عن مرمى الاتحاد
[تصفيق]
فاز لونهنكي يرد بهذه الكره التي مرت
بمحاذاه القائم
يرتقي لها المغربي عبد الرزاق حمد الله
بين ان راسيته تظل طريق الشباك
اخرى صراع في منطقه جزاء الاتحاد بين
باهابري واحمد حجازي ينتهي بركله جزاء
شبابيه وبطاقه صفراء للمدافع المصري
للشباب
[تصفيق]
الاتحاد يحاول العوده سريعا ومعركه
بالاقدام امام مرمى الشباب تنتهي بتسديده
من حجازي داخل المرمى
[تصفيق]
الطائر ينقذ الاتحاد من هدف المحقق
بعدها بقليل حجازي يتدخلوا لحمايه مرمى
الضيوف
خطيره جدا
ورايه التسلل الحاضره
والاخير يتصدق مره اخرى للكره
الثاني كارلوس جونيور يهدر فرصه شبابيه
جديده
[موسيقى]
عن الشباك
من جانبي عبد الرحمن العبود
ترتفع ضد محاوله حمض الله
[موسيقى]
الاشتباك بين الفريقين يستمر دون تغيير في
النتيجه والحكم يطلق سافيرته بتعادل
الشباب والاتحاد بهدف لكل منهما هدى زين
الدين العربيه
بطوله كاس الخليج لكره القدم يلتقي اليوم
المنتخب القطري مع نظيره البحريني مملكه
المنتخبان ثلاث نقاط لكل منهما في هذه
المجموعه الفريقان التقيا 17 مره في 24
ونص من البطوله الخليجيه حيث تغلبت
البحرين في خمس مباريات وفاز قطر في اربع
منها وتعادل المنتخبان في ثمانيه مناسبات
من جانبه تعرض المنتخب السعودي لكره القدم
للخساره امام نظيره العراقي بهدفين دون
مقابل ضمن منافسات المجموعه الاولى لبطوله
كاس الخليج بهذه النتيجه ارتفع رصيد
المنتخب العراقي الى اربع نقاط بصداره
المجموعه ومتقدمه بفارق الاهداف عن
المنتخب العماني في ما تجمد رصيد المنتخب
السعودي عند ثلاث نقاط في المرتبه
التاريخيه
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لكم على حسن
المتابعه وعوده اليك خالد
[موسيقى]
قال المدير الاقليمي لمنطقه اوروبا في
منظمه الصحه العالميه هانز كلوك ان
المنظمه لا تتوقع ان تؤدي زياده حالات
الاصابه بكبد نايتين في الصين الى تاثير
كبير على الوضع الوبائي في اوروبا وداع
كلوجي الى ان تكون قيود السفر الاحترازيه
متجدره في العلم وان تكون وان تكون
متناسبه وغير تميزيه
فندق انفورميشن حسب المعلومات المتاحه
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه فان الزياده في
نوعين من الطفرات الفيروسيه المنتشره في
الصين هي تلك التي شهدت بالفعل في اوروبا
واماكن اخرى نشارك وجهه النظر الحاليه
للمركز الاوروبي لمكافحه الامراض بان
الارتفاع المسجله في الصين ليس من المتوقع
ان يؤثر بشكل كبير على الوضع 19 في
المنطقه الاوروبيه في هذا الوقت
خلال هذه الايام يدخل علينا موسم الشد وهو
ثاني مواسم الشتاء الفعلي متابعه في
التقويم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
البرد لا يبدا ولا ينتهي بشكل مفاجئ فله
بدايه وشده ونهايه فبدايته مع موسم اصفري
شهر سبتمبر وشدتي مع موسمي المربعانيه
والشرطه ديسمبر ويناير ونهايته مع موسم
الحميم شهر ابريل والشتاء الفعلي 90 يوما
تقريبا 40 يوما المربعانيه و50 يوما مقسمه
على الشبط والعقارب 50 عاما تولد في
تصرفها عسر يسرا على الحالين اشهده وما
ذقت زمان في تقلبه الا وفي زمن قد صرت
احمده وما جزعته على ميت فجعت به الا ضلال
احسدوا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وخلال هذه الايام يدخل علينا موسم الشبط
والشبط ثاني مواسم الشتاء الفعلي
المربعانيه الشبط العقارب والشبت سميت
بهذا نسبه الى الشهر السرياني شباط فهو
يقع في فبدايته امتدادا لموسم الازيري
وسمي بهذا لان الاجساد تزرق من شده برودته
ونهايته بدايه موسم بذره السن والمربعانيه
الان جالسه توصي ولدها شقيش بعض وتقول له
يا وليدي ترى مريت ما مريت عليك باللي
اكله دويف وناره
سمر
[موسيقى]
في الختام هذا تفكيرهم بالعناوي
روسيا تتعاهدوا بتطوير الترساناتها
النوويه والنيتو يوقع اتفاقيه لتوسيع
التعاون مع اوروبا
بدراسه زياده الاستثمارات والوديعه في
باكستان لاكثر من 15 مليار دولار
ملامح حج هذا العام
تتضح ل قيود ولا شروط والعوده الى الاعداد
الطبيعيه
وبعد موجه امطار تاريخيه الرابعه تتجول في
وادي فاطمه احد اشهر الاوديه في مكه
المكرمه
[موسيقى]